-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I am here with the hilarious
Kristen Wiig right here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Wonder Woman 1984."
Now, Kristen,
we always do something fun
when you're on the show.
With that in mind, it's time for
the "Mimic Challenge."
-♪ Mimic challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, mimic challenge, yeah ♪
-Alright, now,
here's how it works.
We have a bunch of items
to make noise with.
We're gonna take turns making
a sound with an object,
and then the other person has to
immediately match that sound
as precisely as they can.
-I'm so bad at this.
I don't know why
I said yes to this.
-No, I think --
-No, I'm so -- Okay, we'll see.
-We're gonna
match the sound effect.
People have been doing it
on TikTok.
I've seen it. It's funny.
It's fun.
I will make the first noise,
and then I'll say,
"Kristen, make this sound,"
and then you'll say it.
-But I'm watching what you --
-Yes, you're watching.
I'll say,
"Kristen, make this sound."
I'll do the sound,
and then you have to make it.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Kristen, make this sound.
[ Clicks ]
-[ Imitates clicking ]
[ Ding ]
-[ Laughs ] What?
That was fantastic.
Alright, now this is your turn,
whenever you're ready.
-Okay. Jimmy, I need you
to make this sound.
[ Ripping ]
-[ Imitates ripping ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
That was good.
-Kristen, make this sound.
[ Tearing ]
-[ Imitates tearing ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-Jimmy, please make this sound.
[ Crunching, popping ]
-[ Imitates crunching ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
Oh, my God!
-Kristen, make this sound.
[ Squeaking ]
-[ Imitates squeaking ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ] So bad. Terrible.
Okay, Jimmy,
please make this sound.
[ Rattling ]
-[ Imitates rattling ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-Something like that?
-Yes.
-Alright, Kristen,
make this sound.
[ High-pitched squeak ]
-Wait. Do it again.
-[ Imitates squeaking ]
[ Ding ]
-Oh, my God!
You're actually
phenomenal at this.
This is unbelievable,
how great you are.
-Oh, come on. Okay, ready?
-Yeah.
-Make this sound.
-Oh.
[ Knocking ]
-[ Clicks tongue ]
[ Ding ]
-That was amazing.
-Not bad?
-No, that was good.
-That was a tick-tocky.
-That was good.
-I got tick-tocky in there.
Alright, here we go.
Kristen...
-Wait. Which part?
The whole thing?
-No, no, no.
That will be too hard.
Alright, how about this part?
Ready?
-Okay.
Kristen, make this sound.
[ Gurgling ]
-[ Imitates gurgling ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy...
-Yes?
-Ready? Make this sound.
-Yeah.
Wait. Hold on.
[ Rips, whooshes ]
[ Laughter ]
-Can I hear it one more time?
-Yes.
[ Rips ]
-[ Imitates ripping ]
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
-Was that bad?
-That was good.
That was good.
-Alright, Kristen,
make this sound.
[ Whirs ]
-[ Imitates whirring ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
Oh.
[ Whirs ]
[ Imitates whirring ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
Okay. Make this sound.
[ Clicking ]
-[ Imitates whooshing,
clicking ]
[ Ding ]
-Yeah.
That was hard.
That was really hard.
-Alright,
Kristen, make this sound.
[ Buzzing ]
-Do it again.
[ Imitates buzzing ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
Okay. This is your last one.
This will probably be
my favorite.
-Alright, I got to
nail this one.
-Can't believe
I don't own one of these.
-Here we go. Oh.
[ Honking ]
[ Imitates honking ]
Something like that? Not bad?
Alright, I tried.
-That was amazing.
-Dude, you crush at this.
Kristen Wiig, everybody!
"Wonder Woman 1984" will be in
select theaters and IMAX
on December 25th
and on HBO Max the same day.
And watch Kristen
host "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend!